[Music]
a college's graduation rate
clearly indicates how successful a
school is at ensuring their students see
the returns on their investment
because the financial rewards of college
kick in only after a student has
completed their credential
but you might be shocked to learn that
across the board
graduation rates are dismal and if you
only attend some school but don't
graduate
you're actually more likely to have a
hard time paying back your debt
than the average graduate with a larger
balance
there are two things you should do to
mitigate this risk
most importantly enroll at a college
with a high graduation rate
and borrow if you need to studies have
shown that students who borrow less
sometimes don't graduate borrowing to
facilitate your learning can actually
help you financially in the long run
for the 90 of aspiring college students
who report that their number one
motivation for going to college is to
earn more money and to advance in their
career
graduation rates are what matters most
did you consider college graduation
rates when you picked your school
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like to see us
cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei